30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play
hi I'm Joanna sir today's workout is
going to be a really fun one it's going
to be a car cardio and plank hit workout
so we want to be working on your abs but
at the same time we want to increase
your heart rate by doing explosive
movements it's going to get you sweating
and your core will be on fire so try to
keep up
[Music]
there will be four exercises for each
circuit so we want to start with an ab
workout and then to a plank cardio and
end it with an active rest okay so a
total of three circuits let's get
straight down onto the mat for the first
workout which is going to be an e to V
tax all right so place your palms facing
forward legs straight what I want to do
is drive your knees close to your chest
keep it straight and into a V tax
alright 30 seconds for each exercise
good straight in and up good there you
go so you should feel your lower abs as
well as your upper abs start easy this
is only the beginning of your workout
good so drive your upper body close to
your knees as well in straight up and in
and straight up okay so straight into
plank and we want to be doing plank
jacks alright so get into a high plank
let's hop out and in let's go pop out it
in good as wide as I can and drive both
legs back in together strong plank okay
and just look straight onto the floor
and breathe
going fear the work on your car and your
heart rate slowly increasing all right
let's get up okay this is going to be a
fine one explosive cardio jumping lunges
okay so start on your right side explode
to your left and to your right good keep
going if this is too tough beginners you
can always do alternating lunges well
it's going to be a killer
let's go up and down up and down and
after this you're going to have an
active rest good last few more
that's one more and good let's get down
into a plank active stretch reach
forward open up the hip flexor back left
open up the hip flexor straight back and
just stretch it okay 30 seconds
alternating between right and left good
and now let's just raise your right hand
up back down step back up and good few
more feel that deep stretch on your hip
flexor up down
and straight into me to via tax okay get
back down onto the mat okay just support
your upper body using your arms let's go
knee V tucks whoa I can already feel my
heart rate raising good up and straight
ah this is only the first second okay
stay with me straight legs tuck it in
drop your chest closed up and straight
into plank Jack okay ten seconds break
breathe it's your precious ten seconds
and let's go out an end
remember to Peter breathing find your
rhythm keep going
smile okay you are doing good last few
more stay strong and we want to get back
onto our feet all right get back up okay
beginners if you are struggling with
jumping lunges what you can do is
alternating lunges okay so step back
step forward and change side okay this
is an option if this is too easy then of
course by all means get into jumping
lunges explode and explode good halfway
there
drive it up push through your heels up
do your thighs burning
that's two more last one more ahh
get down into a plank hip flexor stretch
okay this is probably your favorite part
so open up let's go play let's like take
this movement to just stretch up and
bring your heart rate down slightly okay
this is the end of your first second
and we want to move into the second
circuit up back down stretch up down
good you're going to get 40 seconds rest
all right
awesome grab some water it's always very
important to keep yourself hydrated
oh my heart rate is just up right now
it's high but I'm feeling really good
okay second second again we want to
start by working on your abs all right
so just lie down the first workout is
going to be bicycle crunches okay so
place both hands close to your head
all right and ready let's twist and
drive your right knee to your left elbow
okay
crunch it just like you're cycling a
bicycle all right keep going feel your
obliques
without as you come up okay
do not pull your head just gently
support your neck now son more all right
get up now it's on to vitamins Frank
still working on your obliques all right
let's go stay with me I told you it's
not going to be easy but it's going to
be awesome you're going to really feel
the work that you have put in keep going
crunch it drag the knees close to your
elbow
do the squeeze on your obliques good
okay as far as you can't crunch and
right after this let's get back on to
your feet 180-degree squat jump huh
another explosive movement so let's
start on your right side okay
squat jump and rotate jump and rotate
remember to drive your butt down alright
but down drive and hop power up using
your quads your glutes and everything in
you last few more give me two more plus
one more ah just rest it haha okay let's
get into some side stretch okay so just
dropped you on there and drop to your
right okay
tap down if you want to and this is your
active recovery drop and just feel the
stretch on your quads and your inner
thighs good drop it
breathe tap and up okay
it flowing and breathe take this
precious 30 seconds to just breathe good
tap last one tap I know let's get back
down onto the floor bicycle crunches aah
trust me I threw the struggle as much as
you do
ok crunch it up and twist when I'm not
talking you know that I'm struggling ha
ha but do you know what if I don't stop
you don't stop okay just keep going we
don't stop right now we stop when we're
done
not when we're tired ok team strong
let's keep going up spider-man plank
Oh quick transition no time to waste
all right into a high plank ready let's
go drive your knee close to your elbow
ok if you can tap and tap good keep
going
halfway there and right after this it's
going to be an explosive cardio workout
[Music]
ah okay wipe your sweat all right let's
start on our right side this time okay
Rio to explode and hop to the other side
let's go hop oh good
explode use the power from your heels
push squat low drive it up okay
always remember to keep your knees bent
do not land with your knees straight
okay squat down drive down and up you
have two more last one and stretch it
okay good slide stretch okay so lunch to
your side stretch it off and to the
other side if you want to you can point
your toes out 20 out through your glute
stretch and your inner thighs okay
stretch it good keep moving very good
that's in your core look straight ahead
okay and this is the end of your second
circuit shot rest straight on to the
Third Circuit
ah okay forty seconds rest if your heart
rate is pumping let me know in the
comments video okay - okay - down one
more to go you got this
we're this just do it alright
okay now let's get back down onto the
mat again starting on our core reverse
crunches I want you to place both hands
just by your side all right and keep
your leg straight and now let's raise it
up
lift your butt off slightly control it
back down up butt up and back down the
work should be on your lower abdominals
up control it okay don't just let your
legs drop upper control nice and
controlled back down and up good keep
going
let's do more and plank plank up down
all right
this is going to work more on your
shoulders as well as your arm okay let's
start from a low plank and back up down
and now on the left side don't and
alternating on the right side and back
down so left push left down right push
and right down okay good keeping your
body straight avoid swing from left to
right this is wrong so keep your body
firm and push yourself back up using the
strength from your core and your upper
body okay let's get up all right
plank to hip rafter so from a plane what
a way to do is hop release your hands
and get into a squat okay back into a
plan and a squat thrust all right good
hop back play and squat thrust
beginners if this is too difficult what
you can do is step in and lift yourself
straight up if not hop hop in release
hot back hop in and release okay let's
go bring it up back down and up and oh
okay final stretch plank
to downward dog okay so let's start in a
high plank and get into a downward dog
active recovery back into track and try
to bring your heels close to the floor
if you're struggling then you can always
start tiptoe plank now a dog push
through your back being stretched out
right and last one downward dog and good
second round oh my god let's lie
straight down and it's going to be a
lake race okay so I'm just by your side
and lift your butt off slightly up push
it off and control you back down up lift
it off
feel the squeeze on your lower abs
crunch it and push it up good just a
very small but effective movement up
control last one control and back okay
plank up down this is actually one of my
favorite playing variations okay
starting a little plank let's start on
our right side okay good
alternating on your left back down and
up remember avoid swing your hips too
much up
and down don't just collapse control
every single move up and down you are
strong okay that's one more back down
and just rest for a little while
plank to squat trust it okay all right
let's get into a high plank
let's go hop in and out back drive your
heart rate up this is your last chance
to drive it up good plank
squat thrust keep going you're halfway
there
speed it up let's go as many as you can
in the last ten seconds okay let's go
keep going few more and good final
dynamic stretch plank to downward dog
okay you are almost there
plank downward dog just slowly bring
your heart rate back down plank and
downward dog really push through your
heels and push into your palms
that's one plank
you down with dog
you're done high-five amazing effort
when do I ever leave you
not sweating if you are touring like me
and if your heart is still pumping let
me know in the comments below okay do
this workout consistently at least two
to three times weekly and trust me you
will start to feel the difference on
your body as well as strength from your
core and your total body okay so be sure
to combine in this workout with my other
workouts on my youtube channel do check
out other worker challenges recipes and
also fitness tips on my youtube channel
and remember to give this video a thumbs
up hit the subscribe button and most
importantly guys is to turn on your
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I upload a new video
all the best